she's her own office where she gets all
her business done
this is where you get to hang out when
you come to work
[Music]
at kylie cosmetics headquarters it's
always
take your daughter to work day i feel
like i'm getting into so many
cool beauty things that's kylie jenner's
three-year-old daughter stormy
stealing the show in episode 2 of the
beauty mogul's youtube series
taking fans inside her billion dollar
empire
kylie is so smart so creative so full of
ideas
she truly disrupted the entire beauty
business
to celebrate the company's relaunch as a
vegan brand
kylie brought film cameras into her
offices
quiet on the set shut up
just kidding which included multiple
sit-down interviews with kylie
her mom chris and the kylie cosmetics
team
all of whom seem obsessed with young
stormy i mean
i i think that there's you know one day
we'll be working for stormy too probably
so
well hey stormy already has her own
office so
they might not be too far off kylie goes
to work
with stormy and stormy loves it she just
you know absorbs it this is where you
get to hang out when you come to work
but the highlight of these sneak peeks
has to be stormy's love of candy
oh okay get out of here
get out of here and
kylie isn't shy about the fact she's
trying to emulate her own business savvy
mom
being a mom has become second nature to
me this morning
had to get up at 7am make her breakfast
get her ready
meanwhile i'm in my pajamas and slippers
and i'm like
doing her hair she looks perfect i think
it was just a no-brainer for me
and my mom and our team to just be
surrounded by
strong women i hope stormy looks at me
the way that i look at my mom
say hi mommy hi daddy likewise chris has
nothing but admiration for how her
daughter balances work and family
which is high praise coming from the og
momager she could be
in the middle of the most important
thing
in her life at that moment and if stormy
walks into the room and says mommy i
need you she will
put that on hold and turn all of her
attention
you know to her daughter upon kylie
becoming the youngest
self-made billionaire chris told e.t how
proud she is of her youngest kid to rise
in the business world
miss kylie's going to be here and about
to be a billionaire
is that insane how proud are you she
works really hard i think i'm proud of
all my kids because they really have an
amazing work ethic
and they roll their sleeves up and
really do what they love to do
so that makes me really happy like with
kendall and her modeling she just knew
what she wanted to do
same with kylie and her makeup it's they
all find their passion
and when that happens it's like it's
[Music]
magical
you